buying clothes has never been easier
eighty billion items are manufactured
every year we're putting too much
product out there most of their product
ending up in landfill so-called
fast-fashion allows consumers to buy
more but they're wearing these garments
less often and disposing of them at an
unprecedented rate
[Music]
this is where wardrobe castoffs end up
Savannah rags is a clothes recycling and
processing plant in Nottingham England
they process discarded clothes from
recycling bins around the country
Mohammed Patel has been running this
plant for 12 years
majority of it will go to Africa and the
white we sent some across the Europe and
we have a couple of spires here in the
UK debate on the golfing globally
sorting plants like this only deal with
around 25% of discarded clothes in
Britain more than 300,000 tons of
clothes end up in landfill every year
it's the fastest-growing category of
waste in the country but this is a
global problem expanding middle classes
in emerging markets are hungry for more
and cheaper fashion it's estimated that
by 2050 global clothing sales could more
than triple one of the things that we've
noticed that the quality of the actual
material being used have gone down we're
now having to process a lot more just to
get the same quality of goods that we
can sell on but how can the fashion
industry continue to grow while
addressing the environmental need for
people to buy fewer clothes New York
fashion is that ajar Mikkola is less
about rags and more about the latest
runway fashions because I post often on
Instagram there is a little bit of
pressure to have a new outfit
[Music]
she's a fashion blogger her stylish
posts and clothing tips are attracting a
big online following I found myself
before buying a lot of clothes I usually
bought clothes from H&M and Zara or ASOS
if you're looking for trendy pieces they
have them they're pretty affordable
[Music]
today she's looking for a new outfit for
a swanky industry event but this store
doesn't sell clothes it rents them a
JAMA has been championing rent the
runways of radical new approach to
high-end fashion rent the runway is a
clothing borrowing service which allows
you to rent clothes for either 4 or 8
days at a time you are cycling through
clothing as fast but you're borrowing it
with other people so other people get to
wear the same things that you're wearing
as well on average only 20% of clothes
are worn on a regular basis rent the
runways mission is to change consumers
relationship with the clothes they wear
rather than buying something only
getting to wear it maybe three four
times before you decide to give it away
or throw it away an item is worn a lot
more when it is being shared across
different people rent the runway only
has a couple of flagship stores but
online it's a giant and it's disrupting
the fashion industry to date there are
10 million members so it comes with a
hefty laundry bill the company claims to
have the largest dry-cleaning facility
in the world Rent the Runway is getting
more mileage out of items of clothing
it's also helping to tackle an
increasing throwaway culture but the
last thing clothing brands want is for
consumers to buy less except perhaps for
Patagonia an outdoor apparel brand which
sent shockwaves through the industry
with this full-page advert in the New
York Times on Black Friday 2011 here in
Amsterdam
Ryan Garrett heads up Patagonia's
operations in Europe and the Middle East
the apparel industry has become one of
the most polluting in the world as an
industry we're creating product that
people don't need by stimulating demand
and creating this sense that if you
don't buy it now it's not going to be
available there's this race to the
bottom on price in quality that is an
unsustainable model Patagonia's
philosophy flies in the face of fast
fashion to buy once buy well and mend
clothing for a longer lifespan so maybe
doing that in Amsterdam and then
figuring out how to share those work
with the largest single repair facility
in North America and mobile mending
services around Europe and America
Patagonia's anti-fashion environmental
message has resonated with people who
buy into their vision helping our
customers keep their product and used
longer was also one of the original big
ideas of Patagonia
between 2008 and 2014
profits reportedly tripled Patagonia
claims it generates revenue of nearly 1
billion dollars a year it's hope is to
inspire other brands to tackle the
environmental impact of fast fashion if
I had the opportunity to sit down with
leaders from some of the bigger fast
fashion companies in the world what I'd
really encourage them to understand the
full impact of their supply chains
Patagonia provides a glimpse into a more
enlightened approach to fashion but
they're a rare example from a hannett
the boom in fast fashion has been good
for business but this throwaway culture
sits uncomfortably with him
sometimes it's soul-destroying because
you come to work neither thing is this
what we've come to that the human race
or we think about is dispose of things
the environmental impact on the planet
is just colossal and I don't think we as
the human race realized what it is that
we're doing just for the sake of wearing
a pair of jeans in order to tackle the
throwaway culture brands and consumers
need to change their behaviors industry
pioneers are proving that there are
viable business opportunities in selling
less others need to follow suit